The House held
its first public hearings
in the impeachment inquiry
today.
And there was a major
new bombshell
about President Trump's
involvement
in the Ukraine scandal.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today was a historic day.
This was only the fourth time
in American history
that Congress has launched
public impeachment proceedings
against a sitting president.
And that is not a club
you want to be in.
There are the two presidents
who actually got impeached
and the third, Richard Nixon,
who was so desperate
to avoid it, he quit first.
Remember the famous shot of
Nixon getting on the helicopter?
If that had been Trump,
the Secret Service would have to
tie him to the helicopter
by his leg and airlift him out.
[ As Donald Trump ]
Please drop me off at a Wendy's.
[ Normal voice ]
Democrats have already collected
reams of damning evidence
and witness testimony
in private depositions.
That evidence has been
so compelling,
even some conservatives have
called for Trump's impeachment,
like George Conway,
the husband of White House
counselor Kellyanne Conway.
Conway made a rare TV appearance
on MSNBC today,
where he was asked specifically
how he talks about
his criticisms of Trump
with fellow Republicans.
-This is about the country,
people doing the right thing
by the country
and not by their party.
And this is about
telling the truth
about what really happened
and not about party loyalty.
-Are you disappointed
that Republicans
don't seem to see it that way?
-I'm horrified.
I'm appalled.
-If you're alone
with a Republican --
You spent your career
in Republican legal causes.
What is the case to
the Republicans you've known
your whole professional life?
-Well, the case is,
take that Republican hat off
and look at it neutrally.
-It is so weird to watch them
dance around the fact
that he's married
to Kellyanne Conway.
"So what do you say if you're
alone with a Republican,
say in a kitchen or in a car
on the way to dinner?
What do you tell the Republicans
you've known your whole life,
say Republicans
you've exchanged vows with?
Just one more.
You're married
to Kellyanne Conway!
What is going on here?!"
Now, once again...
[ Applause ]
Once the hearing began,
Democratic chairman Adam Schiff
laid out all the evidence
Democrats have collected,
all of which
is also publicly known.
And there was one crucial point
he made
that is worth remembering.
-The questions presented
by this impeachment inquiry
are whether President Trump
sought to exploit
that ally's vulnerability
and invite Ukraine's
interference in our elections.
The facts in the present inquiry
are not seriously contested.
-That's true.
Republicans haven't actually
contested any of the facts.
In fact, they've basically
admitted to all of it.
We have the transcript
where Trump mentioned
the Bidens by name
and told the Ukrainian
president,
"I would like you
to do us a favor."
Trump and his chief of staff
have confessed on TV.
And Rudy Giuliani
has done multiple interviews
where he actually showed off
his communications
with Trump officials
on his phone and his iPad
on national television.
You know you're a bad criminal
when you keep the evidence
against you on multiple devices.
I'd love to see
the storage chart on his phone.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rudy --
Rudy's like a bank robber
who says, "Look at my Fitbit.
I took 1,000 steps from my house
to the bank
and then to my getaway car."
Republicans have not challenged
any of the central facts
of the case,
so instead
they just resort to lies.
Take Republican congressman
Devin Nunes,
who decided to double down
on a bunch of ridiculous
conspiracy theories.
For example,
during his opening statement,
he made a truly insane claim
that had nothing to do with
the actual Ukraine scandal.
-We're asked to simply forget
about Democrats
on this committee
falsely claiming they had more
than circumstantial evidence
of collusion between
President Trump and Russians.
We should also forget about them
trying to obtain
nude pictures of Trump
from Russian pranksters.
-Hey, man, I guarantee you,
no one wants nude pics
of Donald Trump.
I'm not crazy about clothed pics
Also, I have to believe
that if there were nude pics
of Donald Trump,
the first person to show them
to us would be Donald Trump.
He'd probably hold
a press conference
with a giant poster board.
[ As Donald Trump ]
As you can see here,
this was a selfie
I took on the toilet.
[ Normal voice ]
Nunes also picked up on a theme
right-wing pundits
have been pushing for weeks
that the impeachment hearings
are just a show
concocted by Democrats for TV
as a sequel to
the Russia investigation.
-What we will witness today
is a televised
theatrical performance
staged by the Democrats.
It seems you agreed witting
or unwittingly
to participate in a drama.
But the main performance,
the Russia hoax, has ended,
and you've been cast in
the low-rent Ukrainian sequel.
-Impeachment isn't
These guys are
the low-rent Ukrainian sequel.
Remember them?
Lev and Igor?
These are the real names
of Rudy's henchmen
who were arrested in part
for their role in the scandal.
At least the Russia
investigation
had guys who looked like
Bond villains and Mafia dons.
These guys look like they should
be Ivan Drago's cornermen
in "Rocky IV."
They look like balloons in the
annual Macy's day perp walk.
Now, compare the Republicans
to the credibility
of the two witnesses --
State Department official
George Kent
and Ambassador Bill Taylor.
Both witnesses directly tied
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
to the Ukraine scheme,
with Kent using an especially
interesting phrase.
-Over the course
of 2018 and 2019,
I became increasingly aware
of an effort
by Rudy Giuliani and others,
including his associates
Lev Parnas and Igor Fruman,
to run a campaign to smear
Ambassador Yovanovitch
and other officials
at the U.S. embassy in Kiev.
In mid-August,
it became clear to me
that Giuliani's efforts
to gin up politically motivated
investigations
were now infecting
U.S. engagement with Ukraine.
-That's right, Rudy was
infecting Ukraine policy.
And that's the right word to use
because he looks like the human
version of the Mucinex man.
But Taylor -- Taylor
in particular is a key witness
because he created
a written record
of what was happening
at the time
by writing down his concerns
in text messages.
And he relayed those concerns
again in his testimony.
-I and others sat
in astonishment.
Ukrainians
were fighting Russians
and counted on not only
the training and weapons,
but also the assurance
of U.S. support.
The explanation made no sense.
Ukrainians did not owe
President Trump anything.
And holding up
security assistance
for domestic political gain
was crazy.
-Yes, it was crazy,
which is exactly why
I believe Trump did it.
Any time Trump has a choice
between doing the sane thing
and the crazy thing,
he picks the crazy thing.
That's true even when he stands.
He has the choice between
standing like a normal person
or standing like a rooster
defending his nest,
and he always chooses rooster.
Taylor also revealed
some damning new information,
information he just
received recently.
Taylor told the committee
that over the summer,
during a trip to Ukraine,
a member of his staff overheard
a phone call Trump had
with his handpicked ambassador
to the E.U., Gordon Sondland.
In that call,
Trump asked Sondland directly
about the investigations
he wanted Ukraine to conduct
of the Bidens.
-Last Friday, a member
of my staff told me
of events that occurred
on July 26th.
A member of my staff accompanied
Ambassador Sondland.
Ambassador Sondland
called President Trump
and told him of his meetings
in Kiev.
The member of my staff
could hear President Trump
on the phone asking
Ambassador Sondland
about the investigations.
Following the call
with President Trump,
the member of my staff
asked Ambassador Sondland
what President Trump
thought about Ukraine.
Ambassador Sondland responded
that President Trump
cares more about
the investigations of Biden,
which Giuliani was pressing for.
-Once again, these guys are
the worst criminals in history.
Think about that.
Trump talked to a henchman
on a phone call
about his plan to extort
a foreign country,
and he was so loud,
people could overhear him.
A good criminal would call
and say, "Are you alone?"
Trump would say, "Are you alone?
If not, go find some people
to stand next to.
Put me on speakerphone.
This is a doozy."
This is a major bombshell,
yet another piece of evidence
that directly ties Trump himself
to this scheme.
We have the transcript,
witnesses, text messages,
and now we have
a damning new phone call.
If we had this much evidence
during the O.J. trial,
even Johnnie Cochran would've
been like, "You know what?
The glove does fit.
My client's full of [bleep]"
This is yet another
new piece of evidence
confirming that Trump had
committed impeachable offenses.
In fact, George Conway
summed it all up
with his very straightforward
statement
about just how damning
the facts have been for Trump.
-It's the ultimate
impeachable offense.
You can't --
If you were going to make up
a set of facts
that were as bad as you
could get, this would be it.
-I agree,
and just a thought here,
but maybe you could write
that down on a Post-it
and leave it on your fridge.
What this hearing made clear
once again
is Republicans have no defense.
They have nothing.
For example, Republicans also
hired their own outside lawyer
to question the witnesses.
That lawyer tried to ask Taylor
about Sondland's involvement
in the scheme.
Again, as you'll recall,
Sondland was Trump's handpicked
ambassador to the E.U.,
not Ukraine.
So it's suspicious he was
involved in any of this at all.
The GOP lawyer tried
to get Taylor to say
that it wasn't suspicious.
But his line of questioning
fell flat.
-I want to turn
to the discussion
of the irregular channel
you describe.
In fairness, this irregular
channel of diplomacy,
it's not as outlandish
as it could be.
Is that correct?
-It's not as outlandish
as it could be.
-That's their best argument --
It's not as outlandish
as it could be.
Trump should just run
all the way with that
and start holding his rallies
in front of a giant banner
that says, "Not as guilty
as I could be."
[ Laughter ]
The GOP lawyer kept going on
with his bizarre
line of questioning
about Sondland's role
in the scheme.
And eventually,
Taylor just gave up.
-His involvement here,
while not necessarily part
of his official duties
as the ambassador to the E.U.,
it certainly is not outlandish
for him to be interested
and engaged pursuant
to the president
or Secretary Pompeo's direction,
correct?
-It's a little unusual for
the U.S. ambassador to the E.U.
to play a role
in Ukraine policy.
-Okay.
And, you know,
it might be irregular,
but it's certainly
not outlandish.
[ Laughter ]
And then Secretary Perry --
-I mean, that was --
That was the entire series
of expressions you make
when a guy comes up to you
on the subway
and asks if you'd like
to touch his pet lizard.
[ Laughter ]
Although probably the best
moment of the hearing today
came when Republican congressman
Jim Jordan
kept obsessing over
the whistle-blower.
-Now, there is one witness,
one witness that they won't
bring in front of us,
they won't bring in front
of the American people.
That's the guy who started
it all, the whistle-blower.
-I say to my colleague,
I'd be glad to have the person
who started it all
come in and testify.
President Trump is welcome
to take a seat right there.
-I would love
to see Trump testify.
Can you imagine that?
After five minutes,
Rudy would probably
be running into the room,
screaming, "Boss, I got
all the evidence right here.
It's in my Notes app."
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
while all this was happening,
Trump was at the White House
meeting with the president
of Turkey.
Now, Trump retweeted
multiple clips of the hearing
throughout the day.
And yet he insisted
he wasn't watching the hearing
because he didn't have time.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-No, I didn't.
I did not watch it.
I'm too busy to watch it.
It's a witch hunt. It's a hoax.
-No, you weren't.
There's no way
you were too busy to watch.
Trump watches TV all the time.
I'm shocked there wasn't a TV
next to him
while he was answering
that question.
[ As Donald Trump ]
I'm too busy to watch. Hold on.
Oh, no, they know
about the phone call.
Oh [bleep]
[ Normal voice ] Today was both
historic and deeply revealing.
It's almost inevitable
that Trump will be
the third president in history
to be impeached.
Republicans made clear
they have no defense.
Their best argument is that it
might be outlandish, but it's...
-Not as outlandish
as it could be.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]